okay food it's free you're still your
sole student you're paying for life go
get the free food that we could put on
the on the web right
oh you hello everyone um I think we'll
go ahead and start welcome to our IDL
talk today most of you know who I am but
for those who don't know this very
quickly introduce myself my name is
Vishnu mohan i'm an assistant professor
in the department of medical informatics
and clinical epidemiology try saying
that three times after four years and
I'm an internist but a few years ago I
had an epiphany and became an in
fermentation which signified a mutation
and a change in the way that I think I'm
particularly interested in how
physicians interact with technology and
how technology either helps or hinders
physicians make the kind of decisions
they need to make and one thing that I
will add is that I'm also a demise alum
so I have a certificate and an MBI from
demise and they can't get rid of me so
now I'm still here I'd also like to
introduce it is my privilege to
introduce today to you Jeffrey Gould he
is an associate professor in the
division of whom very critical care the
Department of Medicine here at OHSU
he's also the program director for the
Plumeri critical care as well as a
critical care fellowships
he is a co-director of the simulation
effort here at OHSU he's also involved
in medical student curriculum
development and wears a lot of hats but
none today it's at the onset of of this
talk I would like to I would also like
to welcome all those people all three of
you who are in cyberspace
hello welcome and there is a Twitter way
to get in touch with us so that you can
ask your questions and that twitter
handle is OHSU informatics easy enough
we'd like this to be a very informal
talk and we would also like it to be an
interactive talk most lectures end up
with people presenting slides and
PowerPoint and PowerPoint has bullets
and bullets can kill you
what we would like to do is to start a
dialogue please feel free to interrupt
us ask questions we enjoy that this is
literally a dog and pony show and you
guys are all part of the circus I'm not
sure which I am actually I'm not gonna
go with it oh and we said we'd start
with a slide that really represents what
we've been thinking about for the last
week very seriously
we both have theories most of it has
happened I think he's a Hydra agent I
really want to start this talk by
placing us in the right context that
that electronic health record adoption
has been or placing us in the right
context with my co-presenter falling
down electronic health record adoptions
rates have been very strange if you
think about the history of EHRs they've
been around for decades the first EHRs
were out in the early 70s and the an
adoption rate were staggeringly abysmal
until a few years ago when Meaningful
Use came on board and changed everything
and now all of a sudden in just a few
years we've gone from EHR still being a
niche product to some degree in many
hospitals to being a universe a
universal product in most hospitals and
in you know to sort of finish that
statement from me as the clinician side
of things who's my background being in
patient safety and health care
administration I was the director of all
the critical care units at Bellevue
Hospital in New York was involved in
implementation lots of each multiple
EHRs I will say right now that the
electronic health record is the only
only medical device used by every single
provider in a healthcare system alright
there's no other thing you know not
everyone puts in IVs not everyone does
central lines not everyone does robotic
surgery but everybody from an
administrator to a nurse to a
respiratory therapist to a clinician to
a PA to an NP to billing people every
interacts with the EHR and the EHR
becomes the central repository for all
information and that information is what
is used by everybody for clinical
decision-making it's used for reporting
on meaningful use for patient safety
right you know when you look and see how
H su compares we're a top-ten Hospital
we're top 10 ounce well why because we
kill less people how do we know we kill
those people because we extract our data
out of the EHR and a chart said we
killed less people all of that data is
it's at the Nexus of every single aspect
of healthcare delivery today so not only
is it just the adoption but it's
Universal in its impact and its use it
really goes back I think to what Joan
Joan ash is here today and what Joan
said maybe we don't go about the EHR see
I just said don't actually say just as
she was like and and and Joan first kind
of articulated this really well the EHR
is the center of the universe of
clinical care that that there is
actually an artifact now and an idol
around which everyone in the healthcare
system
congregates and uses us are found for
information that's never happened before
it's always been not only is the data
fragmented and hard to get at but there
is no single object that is venerated as
equally by all disciplines within the
clinical environment as the EHR has been
and so I mean some hard data to back
this up we know that Hospital adoption
rates of EHR have jumped from just about
12% in 2009 to over 40% in 2012 and
again this jump occurred more towards
2012 than it did towards 2009 that 85%
of all hospitals report meeting some or
all objectives of Meaningful Use that
54% of all facility using an EHR in 2011
and the number is much higher now and
again what I want to emphasize is that
this is a train that is rolling down the
mountain at an extraordinarily fast
speed it started slow but it's not
gathering very much moss it is really
really taking off in the United States
in a way that has never happened
and I'll just if I already put give you
guys by a show of hands
as you know not only is this train
taking off have you guys lived in New
York City anyone live in New York okay
so what's one of the things if you do
public transit in New York City that you
wish you had no public transportation
what's the biggest monthly support
lender that okay so Wi-Fi on public
transit but what's were the big issues
with the subway system in New York
besides that smells that it's hot all
the trains go which direction north
south right
very few crosstown trains right you wish
you could have more crosstown trends do
you know why you don't have crosstown
trains infrastructure what about the
infrastructure well no so here's the
issue in the beginning part of the
twentieth century there were multiple
different companies that owned the
subway lines so the four five six line
which is the IRT as well as I think the
end in the are were owned by one company
the one the numbered lines were owned by
a different company those subway tunnels
are different sizes in the trains are
different sizes so you can't connect
them across so now think about it today
so if the show of hands if you think
there's less than 20 EHR vendors raise
your hand
less than okay less than 60 about less
than a hundred about less than 200 less
than 300
so right now not always this train taken
off but we have 350 different subway
lines in use in the United States none
of which can have the trains go toward
across one another so again when we talk
about the problems associated with this
train has left the station and we
imagine now there's 350 different train
lines each one slightly different tunnel
right because yeah in order for this
subway train to be efficient it has to
match the tunnel exactly otherwise you
get a big wind blast and people fall in
and it's all in the train rattles and
hits the walls and stuff like that it
rattles anyways but doesn't at the wall
so that's one of the huge barriers right
so when we're going to be talking about
in a minute is that well how do you even
use this system effectively
how could you determine a optimal way to
interact with this piece of technology
you have 350 versions at least in use in
this country alone and there's no
standardization on how to make them
there are some standardized codes right
hl7 think for medication reconciliation
but there's nothing that says that an
interface has to have these qualities so
now imagine 350 different subway trains
some could have sliding doors some you
buy your ticket on the train some you
buy it upstairs some uses a code card
some use a token some have straps some
have seats and absolutely some go
vertically some go on slants no
standardization whatsoever so just to
put in and it's put into perspective
what kind of problem that we have to try
to solve now this is the mess we've
gotten ourselves into New York is still
paying for it just for two subway
company wines we still can't get a
freakin crosstown subway in New York but
the problem with healthcare is that
patients are going crosstown all the
time right and they're taking train
after train and system after system and
there's a perception rightfully so that
the trains are not taking patients where
they want to go so if you want to get
from you know the east side of Manhattan
to the west side of Manhattan it's
probably quicker to walk then
a subway so what we want to do in health
care is not only develop train lines
that that work across town but if we
can't do it we need to develop a taxi
service that can very people across town
efficiently so that they can get from
one train line to another and this
segment of this talk was trunk was
sponsored by New York transportation no
it's the NCAA the MTA so I I put this
slide up because we want to kind of
focus on patient safety and and and
errors that creep into medicine and I
will tell you I've been practicing
medicine for some time now and I have
seen things you people wouldn't believe
of attack ships on fire off the shoulder
of Orion I've seen see beams all right
so time for me to leap when I started as
an attending they wanted me to pick a
committee to serve on and I picked the
patient care and Safety Committee in my
hospital because it only met three times
a year and then I thought I was as I was
a very good choice and then Pennsylvania
passed the EM Care Act which required
all critical misses and significant
patient errors to be reported into a
patient safety database and we went from
meeting three times a year to meeting
three times a month and then broke up
into subcommittee so that we could meet
more often because we were identifying
so many errors in the system and I think
we're at a stage of history now where we
think that the solution to errors that
occur because of healthcare and believe
me there are plenty of them we think the
solution is to implement a layer of
technology that will help us to reduce
the errors but then the unintended
consequence of that is that the
technology itself is responsible for
different kinds of errors and we think
the solution to that is to implement
another layer of technology on top of it
that will help to identify and suppress
those errors and this story goes on and
so to give you an example the way I got
into this research is so at full
disclosure I am
basic scientist alright so I played with
cell cultures for a long time I know how
to grow macrophages I know how to grow
neutrophils I play with Mice and mice
play with us there they're fun little
creatures you know it was the four
legged mice not that mouse clicks I used
to deal with I started back at Bellevue
and I used to believe that every single
person who has a cardiac arrest in an
ICU that could be prevented that you
should know when something bad is going
to happen because you have all the data
in the world you have real-time
reporting of all your blood pressures
all your labs and so I would review each
one that would happen because that was
it that was my job I was the director
and what I would find is that for hours
you would see the critical
decompensation of the patient happening
and it would be completely unrecognized
now if you want to say is this unique to
baby we just have bad doctors at
Bellevue well there is a study out of
Australia that showed that up to 36
hours prior to cardiac arrest on the
floor there's evidence of clinical
decompensation more than half the time
is it missed and when it's recognized
less than half the time is it acted upon
so alert fatigue in many respects that
they say there's a problem they still
ignored it when I started off here we'll
show a little bit of our research in a
bit but we weren't lined with that back
one of the things that I did
we had our weekly M&M for our division
every week we do M&M morbidity and
mortality where you review errors or
deaths in your clinical environment and
my fellows said we don't have anybody
like a whole week you guys have been
here and you didn't do anything wrong
like a miracle it's like your kid
actually cleaning your room every day
and they said no we didn't do anything
wrong no problem so I said okay give me
the most complex patient in the ICU
somebody who's been there for a while on
a ventilator on a lot of medications for
their blood pressures and let's pull up
epic and again this case epic being our
in-house EHR and what we did is found
about 15 to 18 different errors that
were completely
recognized by the team best practices
not being adhered to they didn't realize
dangerous settings on ventilators they
didn't realize stuff that was being
charted by the nurses that because they
didn't pick up on it they didn't realize
errors go both ways I was on rounds one
time residence presenting to me says you
know mr. Soto blood pressure was this
oxygen saturations were 92 to 98 percent
and you keep on going yeah let's say you
like okay that sounds great 92 to 98
being quote-unquote normal numbers okay
I'm looking at epic in real time no
numbers have been charted for the last
18 hours
nothing's charted they pulled the data
in from the electronic health record and
it gave the most recent data which was
in that nice range but nothing charted
no one realized that the nurse didn't
realize that nothing was being charted
even though they were responsible for
the charting and the doctor didn't
realize it so again all of these
unintended consequences the last thing
I'll say really quickly before we move
on to the next slide for those of you
who read the New England Journal of
Medicine about two weeks ago there was a
very famous article there's a very
Arizona landmark article that came out
about the use of surgical checklists
this is one of the issues as we tried to
move towards making things safer and
moving things electronic the checklist
slash bullet point has become a meet end
unto itself right pull up something
check the you know how do you know you
did it you check the box and of course
we all do this all the time when we
download an update on iTunes right we
read the terms and services of agreement
and we check the box and I guarantee you
none of you have actually read that
entire thing so what did they do they
had this nice survey this checklist that
had been shown to improve surgical
outcomes in multiple small studies and
then they implemented who implemented it
across the entire province of Ontario
and I've been Don Terry oh they're very
nice people I don't think that they're
the reason that this study failed and
what did they show absolutely zero
impact on clinical outcome
zero-zero and again what it shows is
that when we try to make the process and
end them to itself the unintended
consequence is that you lose sight of
what your meaningful outcomes are and
that's how we get to these unintended
consequences we focus so much on the
process that we don't that we lose track
of seeing does it actually impact
outcome and part of the reasons is
because outcomes are just so hard to
measure right I mean outcomes in
clinical studies are much easier to
measure than outcomes in informatics
studies in clinical informatics studies
because the parameters are different and
the way that we can show cause and
effect is to a considerable degree
different I think the moral of the story
really is that healthcare isn't safe
delicious this is a video game called
surgeon simulator where you are a
surgeon you have to operate on people
but your hands shake like crazy and you
have tools like hack saws to take people
you know to do often elliptic surgery
and you know you end up killing patients
a lot in this video game but real life
is something like this you know in a
video game it's funny
in reality it's not you know just
mentioned all these these issues that he
would face in the ICU
I'm predominantly an outpatient
physician and every one of Jeff's points
resonate with me when I precept
residents we have the same kind of
issues that Jeff does it's just that our
time scales in the outpatient world are
very expanded compared to the time
scales in in in Jeff's universe our
problem is that you know if we both deal
with Swiss cheese the outpatient problem
is there's more holes than cheese the
inpatient problems is that the holes are
all in the wrong place right the other
issue is I think that's really that's
really interesting or maybe important is
that when you are talking about
outpatient inpatient universes what
you're really talking about is a
fundamental inability for physicians to
do what they do and the reason that
exists is because I think we don't
understand fully how physicians interact
with the system in order to get the
information that they need yet and
that's something that Jeff and I are
trying to figure out in our research how
this process actually occurred
we know that that physicians are
expected to engage in in vast amounts of
analytical thinking where they they they
function like Sherlock Holmes looking
for clues and and finding the pieces of
information that help them to build the
case layer by layer brick by brick it
doesn't happen that way what we do most
of the time is look for patterns and if
we can't find specific data in the
electronic health record we can't make
those patterns and if you can't make
those patterns we can't make the
diagnosis and so an electronic health
record that is safe and allows
physicians to diagnose and treat
diseases should necessarily allow those
patterns to be recognized well one of
the things that I always thought one of
the reasons I became an information is
that my primary hypothesis was that EHRs
would help improve healthcare delivery
and that does seem to be evidence that
suggests this right we know the DA chose
increased efficiency of information
storage and retrieval we know that they
improve healthcare quality there's
multiple studies that have examined this
in their own ways most of its brought
out and we know that EHRs improve
coordination and care of diseases I mean
this is really a efficient way to use
electronic health records as opposed to
paper health records we know that EHRs
allow clinicians to deliver better care
although the definition of better care
has almost Clintonesque connotation to
it and we know that CPOE reduces I'm not
gonna go there anymore so we know that
CPOE reduces medication errors and and
and specifically reduces adverse drug
events so there is a body of literature
that is growing over the last 20 or 30
years that suggests that EHRs do have a
role to improve healthcare delivery but
as you'll see in the next slide the
converse can also be argued right and
okay just go to the next slide I think
that'll make it more apparent so what we
also know though is that multiple
studies have seem to show that the EHR
can also have negative impacts on
patient safety and a lot of these seem
to occur to be directly related to the
amount of data
that are required free to get through
meaning that specifically an icy use of
where a lot of these bad outcomes have
been shown so for example Hans study
which showed and at University of
Pittsburgh right they implemented a thr
and they're just due to poor
implementation they saw in a dramatic
increase in mortality why because they
couldn't quit in the orders for the kids
before the kids got to the war because
you can't put in orders on a patient
unless the patient is actually active in
the system they can't be active in the
system till the president their huge
mess still by the way if you go to our
ICU today but patient goes off the
Florida Road dialysis they're actually
temporarily discharged out of the ICU
and they're not actually on the ICU
patient list if you're to look at the
unit census so this problem is still
happens in some ways or another and a
lot of these are due to deficiencies in
cognition and problems with Association
of recognition of data meaning can't you
see the forest through the trees the
example I would give you if you ever go
if any of us ever gets the ability to go
to Mars right the big mountain on Mars
that's about 36 miles high there the
mountain is so big and the slopes are so
gentle you never know that you're on a
mountain even though because it looks
like you're walking on flat ground
because the slopes is so big that's
sometimes what it's like looking at the
data can you see the trend of the data
when you're in the middle of the trend
maybe you are bike riders it's the same
thing when you're on a gentle grade
going uphill and the road is straight
and you have no perspective alright and
this is made worse by the fact that you
have alert fatigue so word fatigue is
something that was it was coined and
termed from the clinical monitor
environment so you go to any critical
environment every time again abnormal
blood pressure or heart rate everything
else something will beat that you it's
the machine that goes ping we always
have the machine that goes ping the
problem is is that in our EHR because
everybody's because at normality is
determined by population as opposed to
by individual
everything becomes an alert so you could
have 40 to 50 lab alerts a day for a
single patient and ICU for example all
of which are completely normal for that
patient how many of you have been told
yeah a lot of you have probably told
you're slightly anemic alright and that
is your normal baseline hematocrit yeah
in the EHR a little red arrow will go
right next to it so now what do you do
if you're a clinician say I know Jeff
he's slightly anemic he's had a bunch of
surgeries in the fat pass it's normal
for him so what do you do you start to
ignore that alert now what happens if it
drops a little bit more now I'm having
some bleeding I still have the same red
arrow now I have to all of a sudden pay
attention to that red arrow or what's
even worse is like what we had in the
ICU just two weeks ago someone who came
and profoundly dehydrated so now the red
arrow goes away because they've
concentrated all their blood cells the
abnormality was the fact that they've
returned to normal so being able to
customize for each individual patient is
what the goal should be but again you
have oh it's almost impossible to do
that with today's current systems
because of reporting structure and what
I will tell you just as the last thing
is there but a couple studies have come
out they're shown for example in
Colorado and they looked at private
ambulatory practices that adopted EHR no
impact whatsoever on med mal claims so
while not necessarily a surrogate for
patient safety you would think that
would be one of the benefits right is
that better documentation and proof yeah
baby reduce money spent on that mouth no
there was an article that came out about
a year ago that showed that providers
who had access to radiographic studies
in their office were actually more
likely to order more and actually
radiographic testing went up so actually
increasing cost so again many unintended
consequences not just related to patient
safety so two real themes come out of
this right one what is normal is not
necessarily normal and because we live
in a programming universe where
everything has a binary value when it
comes to electronic health records it is
extremely tempting to place that
normal limits on a specific patient for
a specific value of of a laboratory test
but what might be perfectly valid in the
outpatient environment is no longer
valid in the inpatient environment so
these so-called normal values are not in
any way indexed or linked to the
situations where normalcy cannot be
predicted and the reason they're not
linked as well I'm predicted if they
could be predicted they would be linked
and the other issue that comes out as
this is that the presentation of data is
also contextual what is important to me
during you know this visit in the office
may not be important to me a subsequent
visit in the office and so if the same
data is presented the same way every
time
there is no prioritization of the way
that data is presented to the clinician
and this leads to serious cognitive
effects because we are bombarded by
alerts that are irrelevant and therefore
if you know one person cries wolf we may
pay attention but if the entire room is
filled with wolves then it is impossible
to predict which one is actually crying
wolf okay so then you guys figure out
well how the hell am I going to solve
this right how we gonna get at this
because now you have three degrees of
freedom you have 350 different subway
trains different EHR vendors you have 50
different provider types in a given
hospital system if not more inpatient
outpatient level of training level
provider administrative clinical and
every case is different right every
patient is different so you have three
degrees of freedom
all of which pivoting and then we're
supposed to be able to understand how
best to use the system by just
observation and that's where our
research has been focused so the moral
of the story really is that the
Assumption the initial assumption we had
was that it was all because of the EHR
III I still attend Grand Rounds or
clinical meetings where we discussed
like mmm meetings where we discussed
where things went wrong with the patient
and at some point in the room somebody
blames that bit and then everybody looks
at me right and
and and I think I think this is this is
a very common phenomenon that we have
seen in the M&M environment where before
there was a significant attempt to look
at you know the diagnostic process and
reasoning now there's a simple way to
end the conversation it's all epics
fault and when you talk to the engineers
who build the system they say well it's
all user error
Boeing never admits or any airplane
manufacturer never admits that they're
at fault right away it's typically the
fault of the pilots and the pilots union
never admits that it's the fault of the
pilots it's always the fault of the
manufacturer and the poor NTSB folks
have to figure out exactly what happened
in between and it's always in the
setting of a tragedy and this typically
happens in healthcare also the patient's
plane crashes and the people who built
the system blame the clinicians the
clinicians blamed the people who built
the system and nobody wins and everybody
loses but I think once we begin to
understand that the errors that occur
can occur at multiple points it becomes
easier for us to try and focus on
individual elements is this an issue
with hardware with software with
implementation or with workflows I mean
Jeff gave the example of the Hans study
and I'm sure pretty much everyone in the
room is familiar with it but I will say
that the initial assumption from that
study was that it was the EHR that was
killing kids but as time went on we went
from could it be the system the software
we discovered it was the implementation
in workflows and we were able to
reproduce some of these problems and
solve them in a very reasonable way by
the way just so you realize for those of
you who don't keep up on the medical
device literature National Institute of
Science and Technology NIST their
statistics will show you that for all
the medical devices that are recalled
which is a sizable number about half of
them are recalled due to a poor user
interface problems with the user
interface so the idea that medical
technology fails us because of the user
interface the device may be perfectly
fine but how the user interfaces with
the device is the problem is not unique
to EHRs and if anything all we're doing
is reinventing
wiill right we are just starting to come
to the same realization now that every
other medical device manufacturer is
known for the last 20 or 30 years so if
the problem is the interface I mean the
most common question I hear which I like
is why can't an EHR interface be like a
video game interface right and if you
look at a video game interface I've
always wanted to present doom in a
lecture and now I have if you look at an
EHR interface well doesn't it give you
all the information you need in a very
efficient fashion I know I know how much
ammunition I have I know how much armor
I have I know I don't have too much
health and if I don't believe it I know
I don't have too much health and I know
what the situation is I know what my
actions are I know what my tasks are I
can actually predict going forward you
know I only have one rocket so I'd
better find that little rocket thing
icon on the ground otherwise I won't be
able to blow up many people now this
seems really interesting and honor and a
an obvious way to fix the problem with
EHRs why can't we design these intuitive
user interfaces because obviously video
game designers have been doing this
since the dawn of mankind right I mean
Doom is not a new game but I will point
you that this is actually a fallacy and
not a solution and the way I'll point
you is to show you a different kind of a
game now this is a game which is very
different from from the preceding one in
the preceding one you only had small
amounts of information that need to be
displayed to the user
at any given time here is a much more
complicated simulation games where large
amounts of information need to be
processed by the person who's playing
the game hopefully mean in very small
periods of time relatively speaking and
the same problems that occur in the EHR
now you begin to see them in the video
game world this is Europa Universalis 4
the only way that I will ever have total
domination of the earth and you can see
that there's a lot of information that
needs to be processed there's there's
shields that means something that
numbers that means something I have some
sense of what the countries are but
because this is a video game they don't
make sense anymore and the interface the
way that I can actually interact with
the system is hidden in a corner it is
unintuitive it is clunky I never get my
hands on the data that I really want to
take out Aragon which seems to be
somewhere where it should not be
right and and and this is why in North
Africa I'll never know
because pain has expanded yes because
the rain in Spain falls mainly in Aragon
so but when you think in terms of of
what is it that this system lacks well
it lacks clarity
it lacks intuition it lacks the ability
to understand what the information
represents there's too much alerts here
isn't that I mean there's so much stuff
that I don't I don't understand well
this could be an EHR so the solution is
not necessarily to duplicate an
interface from another industry from
video games or from airline cockpits or
from the traditional tropes that you
hear about in an information discussion
board the solution is to be more
intelligent about the kind of interface
that we offer clinicians and we can't
just improve an interface in order to
improve quality of care and reduce
patient errors you have to improve EHR
usability to reduce errors we know this
from the NIST report and also from folks
like Dean sitting we have - who used to
be faculty here until he moved to Texas
and left us we have to incorporate
usability testing into product
development cycles that will reduce
errors that rise because of limited
information visibility something that is
obvious but hard to do and anemia task
force recommended improving usability of
EHRs to specifically enhance patient
safety and quality of care so rather
than think about improving usability as
a general exercise and EHR improvement
it is possible to consider improving EHR
usability from a specific focus that is
patient safety all right so what is the
problem here the problem is that the
user cannot navigate the system
efficiently and if you've seen this
movie good if you haven't seen this
movie please leave now no they go back
in time they have to save checkoff from
a head injury and they have to access a
computer and Scott who as we all know is
a brilliant engineer
is faced with the user interface he has
never encountered before and instead of
using the mouse as it is intended he
says hello computer and expects the
computer to talk back and here is a
classic example of how if we as
clinicians don't interface with the
system efficiently we are not going to
get the voice of major Barrett talking
back to us and what I would say is is
one of the main problems this is when we
do our testing the question is we don't
obviously know where check off this
right so how do you know that Scotty
even if he does get major Barrett Majel
Barrett's boys to come back actually
found Chekov that's the problem so you
may find that yes tell me where check
off is and you find out where he was 24
hours ago not where he is now because
you did not query this system correctly
you may the system may display all the
places check off has been over the last
five days but because of the way the
data are displayed you read it backwards
in time so you read the stuff five days
ago thinking that was the most recent
so again when all the stuff that we're
talking about in terms of youth
efficiently and safely and effectively
using this system one of our I think the
most important premises it has to be
anchored to something you could love to
use the system you can have great
usability you could do all sorts of
usability testing say I love using this
system I think the interface is nice I
like the graphics are nice if you don't
do a good job of actually achieving the
end point of the exercise you're doing
it's irrelevant iPads are pretty you
can't you know Google Maps or not Google
Mount Apple maps when it came out with
the iPhone 5 right it sucked it was
still pretty how did we know it sucked
we knew it sucked because people used
that interface to get to a specific
point and when they found out they ended
up in an alley in a very bad
neighborhood instead of at the
restaurant they want to they said
nice if this interface is not effective
because I know where I was supposed to
be it was supposed to be at the
Cheesecake Factory and I am not there
you know even worse is if you're not
using it for Cheesecake Factory but to
try and and get across from Portland to
the coast and you take the wrong road
because maps didn't get you there this
is Google Maps not not not Apple
you could die right and that's happened
and Jeff hasn't been long in the
informatics environment to know that you
never disabled in an informatics
department oh I don't want but but I'll
say this look at this picture
the only clinician in this picture is
McCoy and he's standing there like a
jackass in the corner because he doesn't
have a clue how to use the system
because damage him he's a physician not
a computer engineer right but that's how
many physicians behave when it comes to
using technology they use surrogates
like scribes they use all manners of
ways to get around the fact that they
don't want to interact with the system
because they can't do it efficiently so
efficient interaction with system is a
problem because if the user cannot
navigate the system efficiently it is a
given that errors will occur and let me
put this way how many of you in this
room have supervised a trainee at any
time good how many do you have in your
time of supervising a trainee have had
your trainee be better at using a piece
of technology than you are because they
learned it okay now how many of those
times when it was that you were
dependent upon the data that that
trainee was giving you it could be
clinical data could be research data or
anything else all right so again think
about it this way you also have this
paradigm where McCoy is now dependent
upon measure this being Scotty being the
intern who actually does know how to use
the technology or this guy who actually
does where's no clinical sense doesn't
know who check off is you depend upon
him to effectively gather the
information and McCoy has no way to vet
that information has no idea how if
you've got it effectively
that's the Scituate
we're in so how can you improve the user
that's that's something that Jeff and I
have kind of talked about for quite some
time and we know very safely right
because we beat on them right well that
would be the best way but I think that
that you have to think in terms of not
just oh this is my solution but what is
out there that that we know about
improving the user that will help us we
do have some guidelines here the safety
assurance factors for EHR resilient
safer guides of which of which Joan was
a big part was was designed to enable
healthcare organizations to optimize
safe EHR used in different operational
areas and the ONC has now published
these safer guides and we we can see
that there is a need for organizations
to follow safety practices associated
with aspects specific aspects of EHR use
such as clinical decision support or
CPOE and providing the infrastructure
and the expertise to allow organizations
to do this seems to be a logical next
step forward in improving the user
however I think the most important piece
here is if you don't train them right
they will not perform right and so using
EHRs efficiently necessitates clinicians
are trained appropriately so in order to
improve the user we have to modify the
training that's given but in order to
improve the training that's given you
have to improve the system so that
you're actually training them on a more
efficient product so there's a from one
of my favorite movies a bridge too far
my wife tells me that when when we were
dating the first movie I tried to make a
watch was a bridge too far and she
doesn't understand why she married me I
do but in this in this movie there's
there's a there's a it's basically the
story of how the allies have to take a
number of bridges in an in a very rapid
period of time in order to allow a bunch
of tanks to go across some major
strategic points and the story goes on
in that direction but the point I want
to make is this that there's a general
who
want to bridge to be taken and he asks
Robert Redford who plays the role of
Julian code how how do you take a bridge
what's the best way to take a bridge and
cooker reply is both ends at once and
when we asked ourselves what is the best
way to to do this we very quickly
decided that we had to build a better
Mouse and build a better mousetrap and
that's really the only way to do this
you improve the user by training them
more appropriately and you improve the
system by improving the usability and
then you use that training and use that
to as an iterative process to inform
each side of the equation so as you
train the users you find out through
certain things that the users will never
get right because of a deficit in the
system right one of the things that we
did in our simulations that we'll talk
about a second is that could pay could
you recognize the sedation scores on a
patient a patient safety item in the ICU
trust me on this one we found out is
that was buried so deep in the EHR no
one was ever looking at it because it
was an area that no clinician would ever
go to so what did we do we moved it back
to a more visible area that's where the
training training the mouse helped us
build a better mousetrap conversely when
you then build your better mousetrap you
need to have a way to implement that
this falls into the realm of
implementation science so then you have
to constantly incorporate that into your
user education so the way we built that
case was that the patient was over
sedated because they were receiving an
excess dose of sedating drugs and the
only way you would know it is if you
actually found the mask or and no one
was actually identifying the fact that
this patient was over sedated because no
one saw the mask or and therefore no one
changed the dose of the drug which was
the appropriate action to take and the
reason they couldn't change it was
because nobody taught them how to get to
the mask or because this would buried so
deep inside the EHR it was difficult
time consuming and nobody really wanted
to do it so just by moving and a data
item to a more efficient platform a more
efficient place in the platform and
allowing clinicians the training that
allows them to actually get there solves
both ends of the bridge at the same at
the same time so we thought about doing
this in real
like right so the question is why can't
we do this in real patients one because
it's not safe - because all patients are
different 3 because you can't replicate
identical data in an ICU environment
between two patients even if they have
the same disease because there's just so
much data and so many variables when
you're looking at over a thousand points
of data per patient per day that is just
you know there are so many permutations
and combinations that the only way to
standardize the experience for subjects
is to is to do a simulation but that
simulation cannot be the same kind of
simulation that you find as default in
the electronic health record because if
a simulation isn't real
the subjects aren't going to have any
kind of realistic experience so there
are certain specific factors of the
simulation that are essential in order
for it to be high fidelity and what I'll
say by is sort of you know so Socrates
said or Plato said as Socrates voice
whereas in essence I think it was in the
Republic that to paraphrase the own no
one knows absolute truth right
because or no one lies because the only
way you can lie effectively is to have
apps knowledge of absolute truth right
because then you can't really be lie yes
total absolute sure and so the problem
with using real cases is you don't know
the absolute truth in those cases
because there's so much data you don't
know what you may even if you dive in
you may not know what's going on so what
you do is you create the constructive
lie where you know what is going wrong
with the patient and what needs to be
identified and why is this so important
I'll go back to the Google Maps / Apple
maps even though I will bash Apple again
you have to get to the Cheesecake
Factory but if you've been there 50
times whether you use Google Maps Apple
maps or ways whatever it is you will go
there regardless of what the mapping
function will tell you you know the way
to go there you've been there 30 times
the key for that mapping app is whether
when your five favorite ways of getting
there are closed can it take you through
all the back roads that still get you
there right that's the key that's what
you want in that scenario that's the
issue with cognitive and anchoring bias
and that's what we wanted to overcome as
well so it's not just a question to
finding the data in the EHR
question can you find the creek can you
find the CB can you find the sedation
scale can you find the blood pressure
the question is is can you recognize
that data in a way to actually make an
effective clinical decision and the best
way to know whether you're effective at
doing this is can you recognize the
unexpected because if you are if all the
data are congruent with the clinical
information that the provider has
they're going to get it right no matter
what but if they're expecting that a
leads to B and it provide tells you yep
B is what's going on well you have no
idea if that was an effective user
interface they guessed right they
guessed right because they had momentum
they had clinical momentum they had
anchoring bias all of which fed into it
the question is is can the provider take
that data and realize if that be it's C
and so again the cases that we create
with the control why doing it on a
mobile testing station identical to what
we used in the ICU and doing it in the
ICU for these cases and when we built
these cases as we put five days worth of
data in there so that they're actually
data rich they have all the blood
pressure values for five days all the
laboratory values all the nursing data
for five days we build in some patient
safety issues that need to be recognized
and then what we do is we say well real
white we want to see if real life users
could use this system so what does that
mean one we give them some information
in advance we tell them what their
colleagues would have told them about
the patient because that's what happens
in real life
and B or two or Roman numeral two I keep
I keep changing my bullet points is that
it's a time-limited exam
reality is resident doctors on the wards
don't spend an hour reviewing the chart
on each patient they don't have the time
so this is a timed exam do you get 10
minutes review the case tell us what's
going on and we have a set checklist to
say do you recognize these things did
you recognize the change in the
hemodynamic did you recognize the
problem with the laboratory values did
you recognize the fact that with those
change in laboratory values and change
in renal function tindy functions that
the medications are now dosed wrong the
participants are then score
on what percentage of those items that
they recognize and then are immediately
debrief that's the purpose of simulation
the simulation is not effective because
of the exercise it's effective because
of the debrief that happens afterwards
where we then go through in the
electronic health record all the
different places where they could have
seen this data how you could have
graphed it how you could have trended it
better then what we've done is we've
incorporated two things into this one we
have multiple cases so what does that
mean now we could take someone and have
them go through it again and see did
they work now whether this was better
EHR skills or better cognition because
we were able to incorporate the EHR into
their learning I can't tell you yet
the second is can we use these
standardized cases in a standardized
environment with lots of users within
the same department to come up with for
this group some general trends of EHR
usability what makes a good user what
makes a bad user and we could do that by
incorporating eye tracking so this is a
commercial eye tracker by toby systems
and what it does is just like you do in
website design or anything else we could
see where you look how long you looked
and how often you looked at it so it's
and I think before I get I think I think
one point I'll make really quickly and
that is that that it sounds evidence
self-evident when you say it you know
you got to do it this way it's got to be
sanitized patients it's got to be high
fidelity so no one's done this but we
had no idea when we started this whether
it would actually work out I mean there
was no guarantee that that this
particular simulation environment would
would be effective we knew that that
simulations allow the replications of
clinical scenarios in a reliable and
consistent fashion not in the healthcare
literature but you know NTSB simulation
studies on crashes allow you to to
reproduce the same set of scenarios and
planes we know that user errors related
to poor reliabilities may be reduced by
room by using simulations to evaluate
EHRs and ist told us this and we have a
sense of off of this from from
interesting things like automobile
dashboard designs where they have you
know the a certain switch or a certain
button in a different place and see how
that affects drivability when you know
an old lady
with a carriage with twin babies as
crossing the road just-just-just in
front of the of the simulation we know
that simulations are now different
usability scenarios to be tested without
patient harm that's obvious and I think
that was our driving force because
because you can't keep testing these
EHRs on real-life patients especially
when you are messing with the usability
because you know changing the
infrastructure changing the the
interface leads to unintended
consequences which leads to more changes
in the interface which leads to
unintended consequences and we've seen
in the informatics literature that it's
not the intended harm results that
destroy the science it is the unintended
consequences that plays such a heavy
burden on the research and simulations
allow a controlled environment where
human factors can be tested by using
usability environments so we came up
with a fundamental hypothesis so we felt
the development of EHR simulation for
the ICU word Roman numeral one helped
identify patterns of effective and
ineffective navigation of our electronic
health record to improve EHR use and
result in better patient safety and Gama
provide guidance for revising and
improving data presentation in the EHR
right so really if we can actually do
the simulations right and develop this
strategy we identify patterns we improve
the EHR we provide guidance for
improving data and we save the world we
pick the ICU because the ICU workflow
looks something like this right and
there's a lot of things happening in
real time in a very confused and
disorganized way and for us it's not
just like as it's not just the
information retrieval that's important
it's not the easy linear workflow that
is the best use case scenario for what
we're trying to prove we want to show
the effectiveness of what we're trying
to do in in an environment where
significant complexity and significant
emergency emergent complexity exist that
allow us to make a better generalization
for the simple scenarios rather than
trying to do this for the simple stuff
and trying to expand it into this
nightmare
so errors of information processing are
on the rise especially in clinical
situations where large amounts of data
need to be processed quickly such as the
ICU we know that clinicians in the ICU
need to process huge amounts of data
rapidly and not only do they need to
process it rapidly everything is
actionable right that data is not that
you process it in five minutes but then
you take six weeks to figure out what to
do with the patient you process it in
seconds and you have a few minutes a
window of opportunity of a very short
period of time in order to make those
decisions and deploy them and the
decision making is very clearly
associated with data processing skills
because the lead time between the actual
processing and making the decision is so
short in environments like the ICU and
just out of curiosity how many data
points do you think we need every day in
the ICU how many if you were to look at
average ICU patient how many data points
in our EHR someone want hazard a guess
say less than five five hundred thousand
2,000 3,000 4,000 you know the answer
this you'd be quieter you've heard this
before so so we're a little bit between
those two so in a study done in 2008
they showed around 1,500 data points per
year but that number was going up by
five percent per year and so I can tell
you we've got it here in our system
right we had 4,000 data points in one
patient in our ICU now each patient
what's an average ICU length of stay
about four days so now you have 20,000
data points per patient just on that
admission alone average ICU census is
about 15 so now you could start to get
an idea of the amount of data that
you're actually responsible for so I
just want to put up two quick pictures
to give you a sense of what we've been
talking about so far first you can see
that almost every lab value in the in
the top graphic is marked with an
exclamation point and and you can see
that that it loses all meaning because
all the hemoglobins are consistent with
anemia so that's fine some of the ones
that are marked before that patient may
not be specific for that patient and
some
that are not marked maybe important and
what I'll show you right now is of the
three that would you would consider
important white blood cell count the top
politically no difference between column
two and column five a little bit of a
wave but not much right hematocrit 2327
that one's actually starting to drift
down a little bit the platelet count to
43 thirteen there's actually a 25% drop
already and still continuing to go down
slowly but surely that may be the one
that you have to keep your eye on the
most it's the only one that isn't
alerted so I pointed you towards the
actual flagged abnormals hemoglobin I
mean how many clinicians in the room
actually took a look at this graph and
appreciated the fact that the platelets
were dropping probably not that many
mainly because it's so small that nobody
could see it but but the point that I'm
trying to make here in both these
scenarios is the fact that something is
marked abnormal or normal does not
necessarily necessitate that it's
important or not and for example here
right - blood pressure readings both of
them are marked as abnormal one because
it's too high one because it's too low
you have no idea that the trend is
actually the problem all right so why I
tracking mainly because all my life I
wanted to build a void cam fishing and
if you haven't seen this movie I also
want to ask people questions like you
see a turtle baking in the hot side but
I won't go there so I think I think the
big reason is that typical traditional
usability studies fail us because they
tend to be talk aloud type of studies
where clinicians are telling us what
they're doing as they're thinking and
there's a huge Hawthorne effect and the
cognitive processes are mainly heuristic
it's very hard to to articulate
heuristic processes in any meaningful
ways and even if they could tell us they
stopped doing what they're doing to tell
us what they're doing so there we felt
that there were many deficiencies with
the traditional way of doing these
studies we picked eye tracking because I
tracking gave us the opportunity to see
in real time what patients were what our
subjects were seeing with respect to
patient data so for example here you
could see this person
looked at all the doses of the
medications but actually never looked to
see whether this medication was actually
administered because this is the
administration time so order versus
implementation perfect example here you
can see the person only looked at the
most recent hemodynamic values so they
have no idea that if something has
changed between here and here they never
looked down here they didn't look at the
entire they only look their trend for a
short period of time and what this is a
tells us is a heat map it changes color
based on how long you look at a specific
period of time and so the more red it is
the longer they've actually focused on
the data so I'm going to show you a
couple pieces of data really quickly
that we get out of the eye tracker first
is as a surrogate for the talked about
studies as I told you we have our
simulated cases where we have these
built in errors we have these built in
changes the patient condition we now
know where these things you could be
viewed in the electronic health record
we go through every ten minute video and
score manually on each screen did you
look at one of these safety items or did
you not we then come up with a set score
of summing it all up a density score and
what you could see is that this density
score on the y-axis actually correlates
pretty well with what you verbalize so
in other words it's becoming a nice
surrogate that we could actually tell
based on this density score how likely
are how likely clinicians are to
actually verbalize and recognize what's
going on in a clinical case for those of
you who are more clinicians out there
this correlation got much worse actually
when R got much better I should say when
we excluded all the progress notes so
the progress notes seem to detract from
the ability to actually clinically
process the data and they do probably
because there's so much junk in them and
I think it's really important for us to
to make sure that the measurement tool
that we are using reflects what we want
to measure so one of the concerns we had
is is that composite score a valid
measurement a valid instrument to
determine what we want to determine and
that seems to be the case the second
thing is is just for those who are
interested in terms of efficiency this
is now again all these are done with our
test environment epic I just want to
show you two things here
first of all in ten minutes average
person uses 20 individual unique screens
to look at their data total of 40 and by
the way progress notes are considered
one screen in toto so if they looked at
30 progress notes we don't count that as
three it's just progress but again if
you look at the number of unique screens
viewed versus your performance on the
simulation how much you actually
verbalized what's going on there's
actually a nice correlation again
showing that people who are effectively
using this EHR now whether this is
universal or not I can't tell you across
the end different vendors seem to be
scanners seem to be able to they know
what everything is it's almost on
autopilot they can look look look scan
scan scan now what evidence do we have
for that is based on whether you look
hard at something or scanned it fixation
versus a saccade a fixation is a date is
where you look for at least 35
milliseconds or more at a data point you
would think that that means you're
concentrating so cogs are the quick
scanning back and forth and what we
found actually is that the number of
cicadas actually correlates much better
with performance than fixations going
into this entire idea of saccadic
decision-making that expert users of the
system are capable of scanning from one
data point to the next in order to
gather as much data as possible to
effect to put it to their heuristic
model of what's going on with the
patient conversely the
deer-in-the-headlights is the fixation
not knowing what you're looking at not
knowing what's going on what's very
interesting is Jenna Marquardt who's
going to be here over the next six
months doing a visiting professorship
and a sabbatical is doing similar work
with ambulatory cases that you mess and
they're finding the exact same thing
with a different EHR vendor suggesting
again the aisle we're starting to get
objective markers were usability and
performance which is so our knowledge
hasn't really been done with EHRs yet at
all so that's about the women of the day
that we're gonna talk about today I know
that we are already a minute or two over
so I apologize we can go on forever as
you probably realize but so um we'll
leave it open to questions and if anyone
has to go I we will not feel insulted we
know it's already 12:30 and we'll stick
around for a minute as well
thank you thank you
a couple questions come in through
Twitter's so the first one is from FISA
and chasse is the simulation environment
based on the interface design of a
single specific EHR correct yeah so
closet yes that what we've done is we've
actually cloned our existing clinical
EHR and populated it with our test cases
so the idea is that when users log in
they have their same user login ID their
same user customization it's our bizarro
work so but the ideas the cases are
created in an Excel spreadsheet so you
could actually if there was an actual
direct interface between different EHRs
we could actually recapitulate the same
case at a different with a different EHR
and we're actually doing that with a
company that we're working with now they
were here talking a little while ago
named zoetic s--
that makes a EHR agnostic vendor we
actually have one of our cases in their
system in order to be able to compare
and contrast so the cases themselves are
universal but the grants that we
collaborate on is on a single EHR what's
your other epic question I mean
everything was a Freudian slip yeah that
was it from Emily hi Emily I'll ski
correctly simulated EHR trait - tag yeah
- a training feedback loop does that
lead to design specs for improved real
EHRs from the many vendors so for the
many vendors I can't tell you what I can
tell you is that based on our data we've
actually redesigned nine screens for our
EHR and created a whole new set of
interfaces that we are now going to be
rolling out and testing for our own
clinical environment so what we did is
we realized that people one of the
reasons we thought they're scanning back
and forth to so many screens is data is
organized by content type as opposed to
relevance type meaning all the
laboratories are all the laboratory
values are together all the medications
are together all the vital signs are
together instead what you would want is
for everything related to the heart labs
vitals medications all be on one page
everything related to infections labs
vitals met
occations culture results all on one
screen so we've now taken that
observation built nine new screens we're
almost done
we're in the second level of creation of
them now mean we have our first draft
and now we have to go and tweak them a
little bit we're now going to be able to
use our one of another simulated case
that nobody's worked on yet and do a
randomized control trial to see does it
improve usability does improve error
recognition and more importantly what
are the unintended consequences to
redesigning the screens this way is
there a possibility that the sheer
volume of data prevents you from
designing an optimal screen that's a
good question right I mean because
because there's so much data and some of
the data is relevant for some situations
some for not we I think when we look at
these high data pathway environments
like the ICU we can make a case for a
better subset than we can for example in
the outpatient setting we wish that we
hope that that there will be these
concentric subsets that you can define
that will allow you to define data sets
that can be imported for specific
scenarios but I think the problem is
immense
that we don't have enough information
about how clinicians interact with the
interfaces in this environment how they
think and process cognitive information
and how that is rendered actionable in
that particular environment so there's a
lot of research that's required in order
to make this truly universal what I
would say is what we need to do going
forward is actually be able to have the
ability to create customized watch lists
for each of our individual patients what
you get to learn them so that I could
create for each one of my patients in
the ICU my top 10 list of things I want
to be notified about that are unique to
that individual patient that would be
one the second thing is is that I think
we have to get away from this idea that
but I'm channeling my inner Chuck Kyllo
for those of you who know Chuck is over
customization is great but
standardization is still necessary I
mean that we should be able to customize
based on workflow and environment but
standardized across users so what we
need is
Tricia's should have their set of data
points at sheets that are useful for
them take out stuff that they never use
but that those data presentation speed
should be different than an orthopedic
surgeon keep it focused for them for
what they're doing so they're not
distracted by data that they never use
but what you need to do is standardize
it across all the orthopedic surgeons I
think another way to kind of put that if
I could add one point to that is we
often think of customization in terms of
customization for the clinician it is a
convenience and a a feature for
clinicians use III I want you guys to
think about customization from a totally
different perspective think about it as
customization from a patient perspective
that the clinicians are able to use the
glass cockpit and the standardized
interfaces but it's really the type of
machine that you're flying and the
people you're flying in that type of
machine that determines the customized
interface I think that throws the
concept of customization on its head
press the button buddy this is
fascinating and you're really hitting on
some very interesting nuances here
because circadian approach is really
important in Diagnostics I because if
you coming at it from trying to process
a lot large information and hang it on
to some sort of preconceived idea of
pattern that's really where you have to
go after lots of stuff fixation that
might be useful in other scenarios so
it's actually may have a purpose a
different purpose and the ICU you
basically set it up as essentially a
scenario simulation of sort of continual
Diagnostics right and and so this is
also it gives us some sense that there
may be other reasons why you may that
there may be there may be adaptions of
the EMR that may be very useful for the
purposes of fixating on words I think
you just kind of touched on that it's
right in that last in that last
statement isn't it in that there's lots
of different uses that people come at
this body at 8:04 and you're going to
probably get different results in in the
eye scans as to that's proven by that my
my goal is you're absolutely right Neil
and Mike you know when I spoke to some
people down at ONC a little while ago
they were saying well how can we what
could we do to improve the quality of
and safety of electronic health records
across the United States you know
they're put in meaningful use everyone's
adopt him they all know that this is
causing problems what could they do to
write it and my answer to them is what
they actually need to do is create a
library of 250 to 300 use cases that
span the spectrum of new admission could
you know follow up inpatient outpatient
across the spectrum so that it would not
matter so to answer Elizabeth's question
if she's still actually listening is
what we actually need is so that someone
could take my ICU case if that would be
deemed a valid case one of our ICU cases
and tested at the University of
Pittsburgh when they're implementing
their new system so that their
standardization in the testing process
as each institution customizes and
implements EHRs based on their own needs
that's a difficult question to answer
because whether the product is now
delivered to the customer is in essence
an incomplete product and and there's
there's a significant degree of work
that the the the consumer does in in
setting up the product the way they
wanted to so what you're suggesting or
the hidden suggestion that you're making
is that you know that EHR vendors
deliver a turnkey product rather than
something that can be customized I don't
know if the business model allows that
at this point primarily because I think
that health care organizations may not
be interested at this point in buying an
absolutely turnkey can't touch it
option and we know this because that's
how the the field that's how the the
area of business has evolved over time I
think we may end up at some point maybe
by Mandy maybe by by other reasons to to
force health care organizations to all
use the same product but I think in in
the political and economic and social
structure in the United States it
be an extraordinarily difficult task to
mandate a standard interface that the
EHR vendor would force on a customer and
what I will say is this just to add on
to your question this is the equivalent
of testing a new airplane under
simulator can in a simulator but only
testing that under normal weather
conditions normal takeoff normal landing
and a completely full fuel tank what the
vendors I think should be doing I would
like for them to be doing is actually
testing the captain Sully right can you
land the airplane on the Hudson River
maybe there's a problem with the design
that you can never do that the other
thing is it's not focused on at all in
today's talk
but what we're still talking about aside
from what we just mentioned today
simulation is a huge part of education
in healthcare right everyone who's done
BLS and ACLs that's simulation right
compress on the manikin and intubate it
do whatever you want
and people do mock codes all the time
we're now working on the cognitive data
part those two have to be married
together and I can tell you what we are
doing is when we actually incorporate
the EHR to our real-life situation we
live simulation training exercises we
uncover even new barriers and problems
with using the EHR when you're actually
having to do it in real time with a
simulated patient with all the bells and
whistles beeping you're forced to make
decisions even quicker type on the run
and communicate so here the last example
I'll give before we we break up so we
were doing this we're doing our
resuscitations in the ICU we had a high
fidelity simulation manikin we had the
EHR incorporated so we had a test case
in there very simple just enough so I
had a couple drug galleries in a couple
old labs but what we want is that the
residents had to be putting in the
orders in real time so instead of saying
give me the antibiotics they had to type
them in so give me the bar data just
like they were with the real patient so
what did we find
so the antibiotic the residence was
something called leave a quit all right
leave a flaw I said it's a quinolone
leave a quit all right so they're typing
it in the resident is talking to the
other resident about what's your
antibiotic to type in there on one whole
side
where this guy is right here they type
it in the nurses are over there by where
Joan is on the other side of the room
they don't hear okay meanwhile the
patient's blood pressure is dropping
down the nurse is over by where Joan is
are saying we need some medication for
the blood pressure we're going to give
levo fed which is a vasopressor you can
see where this is going now can't you
well here's a dish you're seeing issue
you can't type in an order for add or
epinephrine or Levophed
but till there's a weight in the system
because it's a weight based net and they
haven't gotten the weight yet so now the
nurse comes out and says and I'm acting
as the pharmacist on the Confederate and
they say give me a bag of leave oh well
I'm the pharmacist I'm looking in the
system and all I see is in order for
leave a Quinn because that's the only
one that could be validated so what
happened they hung the antibiotic to
titrate the blood pressure which didn't
work so well now yeah this is it for
those was a lie this is a simulated
cases with a mannequin no rush and what
was hurt in this case I was all plastic
damage but these are the ideas of the
type of testing I think actually needs
to be done we have to no longer consider
the electronic health record as the
paper record with a plug it has to be
considered like any other medical device
whether it's your ultrasound machine
your central line kit or anything else
can be integrated into our learning
objectives and the first step to doing
that is one understanding usability of
it and choose having standardized cases
that you could use across the system so
you get replicable results because the
the users and the users are definitely
changing users have different skill
levels so you least have to standardize
the cases so now that Jeff has reminded
us so eloquently that the cup is half
empty I'm going to close this down thank
you very very much for coming and I
think some time to listen to us thank
you